bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 soy lluís Muñoz este 26 de
julio se cumplen 70 años del aniversario
de la muerte de una de las figuras
políticas femeninas más importantes en
la historia de América Latina Eva perón
evita como la conocieron muchos de sus
seguidores es uno de los personajes más
seguidos y admirados en la historia de
Argentina una mujer pionera que luchó
por los derechos de los más
desfavorecidos de su país y cuyo
carácter y liderado causó sensación en
todo el mundo en Frank 24 repasamos su
historia Eva María Duarte nació en la
provincia de Buenos Aires el 7 de mayo
de 1919 Y tuvo una infancia marcada por
la escasez debido a que era una hija de
una relación extramatrimonial que tuvo
su padre una cuestión no aceptada en la
Argentina de la época que la hizo cargar
con calificativos como el de hija y
legítima durante años tras su complicada
juventud decidió mudarse a la ciudad de
Buenos Aires
a los 15 años con el objetivo de
comenzar una carrera artística y es a
partir de aquí cuando su nombre comenzó
a resonar Durante los primeros años en
la capital evita logró ir
estableciéndose en el mundo del
radioteatro e incluso realizó su Debut
en el cine llegando a mejorar
notablemente su vida su crecimiento
profesional se dio mientras a Argentina
atravesaba un momento político clave en
su historia y extremadamente convulso
Eva perón había mostrado desde joven su
interés por el sindicalismo y fue en
estos círculos donde conoció a Juan
Domingo perón en un acto solidario
realizado en el estadio Luna Park en el
año 1944 algo fundamental para lanzar su
carrera política Eva contrajo matrimonio
con Juan Domingo perón tan solo unos
meses después y desde el comienzo se
mostró como una pieza fundamental en sus
aspiraciones políticas históricamente
ninguna mujer había tenido un rol
protagonista en Argentina pero evita
adoptando ya el apellido perón tomó un
papel político autónomo al liderar
varios discursos de la campaña en las
elecciones presidenciales de 1946 entre
sus consignas más defendidas y estaba la
ducha por el derecho al voto femenino
algo que fue un éxito el 24 de febrero
de 1946 perón se convirtió en presidente
y evita en primera dama de Argentina
evita perón aumentó su popularidad entre
las mujeres y la clase trabajadora
puesto que veían en su figura un ejemplo
una cuestión que incluso trascendió
fronteras Eva perón se convirtió en la
sensación política de finales de la
década de 1940 la primera dama Argentina
hizo una larga gira por varios países
europeos como España Italia Francia o
Suiza y por algunos latinoamericanos
viajes en los que dejó muestra de su
talante política al criticar la
situación de muchos de los barrios
obreros que visitaba y al lograr la
conmutación de la pena de muerte a una
presa política comunista de la dictadura
de Francisco Franco en España hechos que
acrecentaron aún su figura tras su
vuelta Argentina evita centrar sus
causas en la legalización del voto
femenino que se obtuvo en 1951 la
igualdad jurídica en el matrimonio entre
el hombre y la mujer la protección de la
ancianidad a través de ayudas que
garantizarán pensiones dignas a este
sector o la lucha para que el estado
proporcionará un mínimo a las personas
más pobres Eva perón nunca olvidó sus
orígenes y detestaba la beneficiencia ya
que consideraba que el cuidado de las
clases más empobrecidas dependían del
estado y no de la Caridad además de sus
luchas evita perón se convirtió en la
persona encargada de transformar al
peronismo desde dentro Bajo su fuerte
liderado el movimiento quedó
estructurado en el partido peronista
masculino el femenino que buscaba dar
mayor protagonismo a las mujeres y los
sindicatos con quien guardaba un
estrecho vínculo y donde gozaba de un
gran apoyo un respaldo que sirvió para
que las centrales obreras y sindicales
promocionarán su candidatura a la
vicepresidencia junto con su esposo en
las elecciones preside de 1951 Sin
embargo Eva perón Tenía muchos
detractores entre las clases más altas
que La consideraban Peligrosa y también
dentro del mismo peronismo esta cuestión
sumada al deterioro de su salud tras el
diagnóstico de un cáncer del cuello
uterino hicieron que evita renunciara al
ofrecimiento en un discurso ante cientos
de miles de personas
[Música]
quisiera siempre el escudo de perón y la
bandera de mi pueblo y aunque dicen el
camino girones de mi vida Yo sé que
ustedes recogerán mi nombre y nos
llevarán como bandera la victoria
evita perón solo pudo vivir unos meses
más después de esas elecciones puesto
que a los 33 años un cáncer le arrebató
la vida su muerte produjo un shock
social en toda Argentina su funeral se
prolongó durante días y millones de
argentinos salieron a las calles a
despedirla el legado de Evita perón sin
embargo continuó durante décadas más
tarde de su fallecimiento incluso hasta
el día de hoy ya que una parte
importante del feminismo argentino y del
progresismo basa Muchas de sus ideas en
ella con esto concluimos Gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]